thank you
what's up y'all sugar Ari Chambers here
from highlight her and I am here in
South Bend Indiana about to honor
six-time WNBA All-Star Skylar Diggins
Smith this is her home court presented
by Zell let's go
[Music]
promises
[Music]
thank you for welcoming me to your home
I've actually never been to Indiana in
my life my welcome to South Bend how do
you define home peaceful is welcoming
understanding this is my first
introduction to everything that I love
everybody that I love memories Nostalgia
you know just all those good old
feelings kind of put into one especially
when I step into this building here in
this gym particularly I find my love for
this game what are some of your favorite
memories and moments from this course
everywhere I go in this building I have
a thousand memories from when I was five
on up to now we didn't have girl teams
to compete against we were playing
against guys teams so I remember just
trying to get your respect on the court
you know all these guys playing trying
to hey let me I got next here let me let
me get on the court I really kind of got
a respect like oh no you got a guard her
you gotta play with her or she could
play that girl got game and I kind of
earned my stripes in this building if
you will that's just what's so special
how Lindsay gymnasium how is actually up
there on the scoreboard
R.I.P Hal rip how my dad was 25 when he
took over this Center his father was a
man in the community he is a man in the
community and now my brother actually
takes over the center and he was the
same age my dad was it hits the fields
you know just to see it kind of come
full circle for me and just that's
really always been important to me to
come around to bring my son around to
see the Legacy continue on and to see
you know hopefully more girls that
follow in that blueprint
hey y'all
thank y'all for coming how does it feel
to feel all this love no these are my
people you know my grandfather I see my
uncle I see my granny my kids from my
team the skydig soldiers coaches people
from all over the community growing up
and so this is just memories this is
Nostalgia for me and it's just so much
love I love you guys so much I'm gonna
call Coach up
you know we used to do all these
fundraisers and we used to you know sell
candy and new car washes right here in
the parking lot right here in the
parking lot you know when you talk about
Legacy it is all about what you can give
back to the community you know I think
it's awesome to have my skydick Soldier
girls here and so you know I wanted to
do something special for you all today
so Zell and highlight her are sending
money directly to your bank account with
Zell to help the program continue the
mission right
[Music]
thank you I don't gotta sell the chicken
I still gonna do some fundraisers yeah
good luck to you guys once again thank
you everybody for coming out I love you
guys I love South Bend and I look
forward to seeing the Next Generation
I'm a direct reflection of y'all so
thank you thanks for coming out
[Music]
is very exciting especially with her
partnering to empower these young girls
this would be something they'll remember
for the rest of their life I'm just
having
such it's been so great today I just
can't wait to see what the team does
it's awesome to see her up there
especially when she plays for Phoenix
Mercury and I'm a big fan of Phoenix
factories I try to interpret a lot of
the things that she does in her game to
my game so that I can be the best player
I can be big
let's go
oh
that got me height
[Music]